Gucci Dionysus
bag. Is it worth it?
I'm Tanner. I've been
deconstructing
and inspecting designer
luxury leather bags
to help people understand
if it's worth it or not,
and I'm going to
walk you through
how I deconstruct the $1,100
Gucci Dionysus mini bag.
The most misused
term in the industry,
it's "genuine leather."
It may mean really low
qualities of leather,
and some people use it
in very misleading ways.
I try to put my estimate
on the leather and
craftsmanship costs
so people can make
that deduction.
Like, how much of this price
is now status coming
from the brand?
And make your mind
by yourself, right?
I look at three things.
First is leather.
Like, what type of
leather selection
was employed in this design?
How good of a
leather is required
for this kind of finish
they employed here?
Two is the craftsmanship,
the sophistication
of the design.
And finally, the third one is
overall performance value
compared to that price point.
If you're looking
for just leather,
you don't care
about the status,
it might be too much for you.
And if you are OK,
you want to buy
the status that comes
with the brand,
then it's totally
worth it for you.
So that's my intention
of helping people
with this information.
This buckle is attached
to it very strongly
through these
metal connections,
and it is really hard
for me to take it off,
so I am cutting the buckle
off from the leather
to take it out of my way
so we can start
inspecting the leather.
Gucci bag has about
two, three layers
of supporting
materials inside.
The leather is backened
by this fabric,
which will prevent the
stretching of the leather over time,
so it's going to
make sure the form
stays intact in years to come.
There are some
thicker supports
almost resembling
cardboard kind of materials.
Sometimes leather
dust is employed
in those support
materials as well
to increase the structure
rigidity of the bag.
This Dionysus bag was very
rigid and structured bag.
It looked, felt, and
stayed very solid
in its given form,
and it was very
well executed.
Super-good craftsmanship,
very good design,
and all that.
Internal pieces was
carefully planned, selected,
and the stitching lines,
even the count of the
stitches, quality seems really good.
I think the shop
making this bag,
definitely a top-notch
artisan shop.
Now I'm applying
some acetone,
because it's a very common
household dissolver,
and I'm using a sharp knife,
or a little leather blade,
to remove the finish.
It's technically
like scraping off
a little bit of a cream
from top of the leather,
and there is no certain depth.
I go until I see
the leather grain.
By leather grain, I'm
talking about the pores
of the hair cells, actually.
You will start seeing the
hair cells beyond the finish
once those plasticky,
gooey substance is gone.
And that gooey substance,
it's just liquidized plastic.
The finish on it,
that pattern-embossed
finish,
is a thick, heavy finish.
Underneath, when
I open the bags,
I know this is good
leather after touching it,
seeing the backside
of it, and all that.
This is subjective.
The leathers I love has
this minimal finish
where I see the natural
grain of leather,
because leather is a
non-standard natural material,
just like, you know,
everybody's skin looks
slightly different.
Truly minimally finished
artisan leathers
make unique pieces.
No two leather
craft will look alike.
That's what I
appreciate in leather,
but I know this is really
almost impossible
for big brands to go
with due to their size.
They need some form
of standardization.
Now I'm going to
cut really thin strips
so I can burn it
and understand from the
burning characteristics
what kind of tanning was
involved in this leather.
Leather can be tanned
different ways.
They all burn
slightly differently,
and they leave different
residues, ashes.
Chrome-tanned leather
burns really slow.
You have to force
it to keep burning.
And then the ashes
will usually show
some form of green residue,
which is the color of the
chrome tanning agent.
90%, in my estimate, of
leathers are chrome-tanned,
because it's convenient,
easy, quick, and very durable,
and everybody uses it,
but it's a heavy metal,
and it's more polluting in
the tanning technique.
Metal-free leather is a fairly
new tanning technique,
I would say only
becoming more popular
in the couple decades.
Gucci bag has a
metal-free claim.
And grain, sometimes
they call it grain
or pebbled calfskin leather,
and this is the little
pebbles they refer to
when they're
talking about that,
which is a
standardization finish.
So the leather they used here
is showing me no
signs of chrome,
which is confirming their
claim of metal-free tanning,
and that's as much as I
can tell from this test.
It doesn't tell too
much of the details
when you're talking about
metal-free tanning,
but at least we don't
see signs of chrome.
In my opinion, this bag
can be made about $115
in leather and labor,
material cost.
It was definitely well made.
It's beautiful leather
employed here.
The quality of craftsmanship
and accessories is exceptional.
Of course, it's a big
brand. It's Gucci.
There is a premium,
definitely, you're paying
in the price of $1,100,
because eventually,
regardless how good
of a leather you use,
price doesn't go
above a certain point
because of the leather.
Then, when you start
seeing astronomical prices,
you know that it's not
about the leather anymore,
it's about the status that
comes with the price.
That's the whole point
of my question of,
is it worth it or not?
Leather is not cheap,
but it's never
astronomically expensive.